what's up everybody I'm Walter Panay
dziak I'm Heather ruse and I'm Ayanna
wave and this is top five today we're
covering a director whose work is so
unique you could usually tell it's one
of his movies within the first few
seconds oh uh give me a hint
okay Johnny Depp Tim Burton has one of
the most prolific careers of any
American director over the last 30-plus
years from live action to animation and
everything in between
Burton has created a distinct style that
is often imitated but never duplicated
starting with his big screen debut
pee-wee's big adventure in 1985 Burton
has constantly been putting out films
that changed the game for one-of-a-kind
storytelling and even technical
achievements not every single movie he's
directed has been a critical hit but he
still been successful in creating films
that capture people's imagination all
over the world
he's even self-aware enough to push
against his own conventions at times and
make a few movies that are very
different from the norm taking all these
into account which selections from his
vast filmography are must-see top 5 best
movies number 5 Edward Scissorhands this
film marks the first time Burton's Muse
Johnny Depp teamed up with him for a
movie guys I think they might have liked
working together when suburban
saleswoman peg discovers a young man
with scissors for hands in the attic of
an abandoned old mansion
she takes the gentle Edward to live with
her and her family
Edward eventually Falls for Peg's
daughter and after a while the
townspeople turn on him citing his
freakish hands and inability to
distinguish right from wrong as the
reasons for out casting him when I think
of the classic Tim Burton look and feel
Edward Scissorhands is most of the time
the first movie that comes into my mind
Burton's trademark design style is all
over this film from Edwards costume to
the cinematography and look of the town
no one else could have made Edward
Scissorhands it has all those Burton
Burton isms that we loved about his
movies but well before some of those
qualities were detrimental to a few of
his later films if you go back and watch
it now you can feel how personal this
story is it's like checking in on an old
friend and remind you why we like his
work so much
Johnny Depp's understated performance as
Edward is one of his absolute best in
fact most of the performances in this
movie are very good the chemistry that
Depp and Winona Ryder shared on-screen
was the heartbeat of the film and just
felt very sincere it's also often
breathtakingly beautiful to look at
[Music]
the contrast of the Gothic in dark with
the bright and chipper really makes this
movie stand out from a cinematography
perspective it's just a really great and
different movie if you haven't seen it
in a while Edward Scissorhands is just
waiting to be revisited number four
Beetlejuice we've covered this before
but there's more than just Keaton's
performance that makes this movie sing
It's Showtime
Beetlejuice is a comedy horror movie
about a recently deceased couple Barbara
and Adam Maitland who are learning the
ins and outs of their newfound death
when their home is sold to a new family
Adam and Barbara learned that they are
tethered to the house and must scare
away the family themselves Lydia the
daughter of the new homeowners is quite
unusual and has a style I've and read
for decades she is capable of seeing the
Maitland's and befriends them after many
failed attempts at haunting Barbara and
Adam summoned Beetlejuice a demon with a
look to die for Jack Skellington is
quaking of course this desperate action
puts both living and deceased in danger
when the Maitland's are accidentally
exorcised Lydia make the deal with
Beetlejuice to save them unfortunately
for her the agreement she made was for a
marriage to the deranged spirit to give
him easier access to the world of living
but all is worked out in an exciting Lee
bizarre fashion chances are if you've
seen this movie you vividly remember the
ending the dance to jump in the line
with Lydia floating in the air is so
amazingly unexpected and by far the most
recognizable scene of the movie it's a
story that's not afraid to take
unexpected turns and never takes itself
too seriously the world-building is so
incredibly playful and dark and the
designs are very reminiscent of Burton's
earlier art the black and white stripes
big eyes exaggerated with dark circles
and snake-like features these are all
things that when you see them you
immediately think of Tim Burton his
style is so recognizable throughout this
film including the light laughs
juxtaposed with Gothic morbid miss the
romanticizing of a small town with
quirky characters is also very on-brand
in step with his other successful movies
the more normal average characters are
the heroes of the story Burton likes to
focus on the strange odd balls of his
worlds the weirder the more wonderful
number three Batman a movie so great
that we've covered it three times in the
past four months on this show and I'm
the only one who hasn't covered it yet
so Dave's 1989's Batman achieved a feat
that many at the time considered
impossible changing the public image of
Batman from a campy kids character to a
dark brooding detective Division that
Burton accomplished with this movie has
changed the superhero genre in ways that
never could have been imagined thirty
years ago looking back now it seems
crazy at the studio handed the Batman
property over to Burton as it was only
his third major motion picture but it
didn't carry the same weight and
Merchandising power it does now I know
the movie isn't perfect and we could
debate for hours about the merits of
Batman versus its sequel Batman Returns
but there's no denying the impact that
this movie had the plot of this movie is
actually pretty straightforward Bruce
Wayne is an eccentric billionaire who
fights crime as Batman after the tragic
death of his parents meanwhile gangster
Jack Napier is double-crossed and set up
on a scheme involving access chemicals a
fight breaks out and Jack falls into a
vat of chemicals causing him to become
Batman's arch nemesis the Joker toss in
a love story with photographer Vicky
Vale and that's pretty much it
but because of the simplicity of the
plot the movie is more character centric
Keaton gives a wonderful performance as
Batman and Bruce Wayne
I'm Batman Jack Nicholson really steals
the show with his iconic performance as
the Joker Jack is dead my friend you can
call me Joker and as you can see
Bernie's unique design aesthetic also
showcased Gotham City
he truly created a plausible world for
all these fantasy characters to be
living in Gotham felt like a character
in and of itself with the way that it
was featured in my opinion that's an
essential part of understanding and
telling a Batman story Burton was really
able to find a perfect balance of dark
and gritty yet still colorful and funny
to breathe new life into a then stale
franchise paving the way for influential
films and series number two ed wood I've
said it before and I will say it again
I love Ed Wood Ed Wood doesn't exactly
fit in as a Hollywood director his
strange personality and eccentric script
ideas make him an outsider however a
chance meeting with former Dracula Beyla
Lugosi starts to change all that with a
team of misfits at his side it manages
to create an oddly appealing string of
super low budget movies this is my
personal favorite Tim Burton movie and
in my opinion it is by far and away his
best film the others we've covered here
are truly great movies but I think they
all pale in comparison to the weird
eccentric charm and genuine heart of Ed
Wood the performances drive this story
and they are incredible way back in 2016
I ranked this as Johnny Depp's best role
and he's unbelievably likable as this
bizarre creative force his interactions
with the late Martin Landau's Bayla
Lugosi are so special to be hope Landau
won the Best Supporting Actor in 1995
for this performance and it was well
deserved let's also not forget about
Bill Murray's strange and wonderful turn
as John Breckinridge do you reject Satan
and all his evil sure in the name of the
Father
putting the performances aside the look
of that would in beautiful black and
white fits the tone perfectly it has
plenty of signature Burton aspects to it
but not to where it's distracting
the film won another Oscar for Best
Makeup so the design of these characters
were also fantastic the way Burton
twists the real Edie Woods life into
this fantastical telling is appropriate
considering who Ed Wood was in real life
the director of the quote/unquote best
worst movie of all time plan 9 from
outer space went through many challenges
to make his films
no matter the quality well I guess it's
the second best worst movie of all time
now the point is Ed Wood is Burton depth
landau and many more at their best you
owe it to yourself to see this one a set
[Music]
and number one best Tim Burton movie in
big fish this movie has all of the
classic Tim Burton quirks
we've got misfits magic brick collars a
circus Helena bonham-carter based on the
book of the same name
big fish follows Edward bloom a salesman
who loves to tell tall tales as he is
unwell and nearing the end of his life
his son will and pregnant
daughter-in-law Josephine visit to
reconcile ed and Will's relationship we
see Edwards younger days through
flashbacks and these larger-than-life
stories become real nothing slows down
the charismatic young man he befriends a
giant saves a town joins a circus and
even works for a werewolf one of the
most beautiful stories is how Edward
meets his wife he falls head-over-heels
for a young woman at the circus and
works tirelessly for the ringmaster to
learn clues about her when he finally
learns her identity and tracks her down
she's already married to a jerk from his
hometown I don't want to give away too
much of the romance so you'll just have
to watch the movie and see how it all
unfolds as will continually tries to
reconnect with his estranged father he
becomes obsessed with catching him and
Ally will travel to the town Edie
claimed to have saved where he meets
Jenny
Ed's possibly not so former flame the
father and sons relationship is strained
while one wants to share his memories
the other only wants to hear the truth
but can memories ever be the full truth
this movie truly has everything you
could want it's smart and sweet but
still his moments of intrigue while the
end is a heartbreaking way perfect
of course Danny Elfman returns to score
the film as well Burton has a wonderful
way of making you sympathize with
unlikely heroes his use of color is so
distinguishable and integral to his
storytelling that so many moments from
this movie are instantly recognizable
any screen shot could be an illustration
plucked from a gothic children's book
there's a charisma to every character
while each storyline is carefully woven
together
I couldn't imagine any other directors
aesthetic being paired so perfectly with
this beautiful story we want to hear
what you guys think what's your favorite
Tim Burton movie what do you want to see
us cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know to keep in touch
you could like my Facebook page or
follow along on Twitter you can find me
on Facebook Twitter Instagram or
subscribe to my animated movie review
series right here on YouTube and you can
find me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter
I stream on Wednesday nights we'll be
back right here next week with the worst
of Tim Burton on a brand new episode of
top 5
hey I just needed to know why the fuck
we didn't have Nightmare Before
Christmas on our top five Tim Burton
list
I mean classic Iona it wasn't directed
by him look at the poster it says Tim
Burton's Nightmare Before Christmas I
mean yeah he was heavily involved in it
but like he didn't actually direct it
himself right story by characters by
executive producer but he did not direct
the movie so it doesn't count
[Music]
[Applause]
you